Like I've often thought of rep of marriage as a wrestling match,
right?
If you're lucky,
the person that you marry is someone you contend with.
It's not exactly,
I don't think it's exactly,
it's not tranquil.
Precisely.
You know,
you might have noticed that some of you and,
but,
but the thing is if you have something to contend against,
then that strengthens you and,
and that's actually better than having nothing to contend against.
And so Jacob is the person who's also strengthened by the necessity of this
contending and that that seems to be the proper relationship with God or the
angel is that contending the battling,
right.
Rather than some sort of kind of loose,
weak statement of belief.
I mean,
I'm not trying to denigrate that to any great degree.
It just doesn't seem like the right motive conceptualization,
right?
Because human beings aren't,
aren't like that were contentious creatures.
And that's actually seems to be something that meets with God's favor in this
situation.
So especially given that that's actually what he names the while the whole
kingdom of the chosen people is the idea is that that's composed of those who
contend with God.
So that's,
that's a hell of an idea that that's for sure.